For this challenge, we are going to need some matresses
This is the right spot for a soft landing
No, that's not soft
Now we have a soft landing
Around the net header
Super head shot
Give me a test one
I'll do one without the dive
Practice one
The Superman shot!
The next challenge is to poke 50 holes into a table tennis ball
And see if we can still play with it
I think this will actually fly quite wierdly in the air
Okay this is well over 50 holes but I think it needs a bit more
Just normal?
Yeah
Okay...
No it's...
It's really normal actually
It's just a bit slower
The sound is a bit wierd
I got a wierd bounce there
Have to be careful not to be the ball breaker on this one...
Don't break it!
Okay so that didn't bounce wierd enough so we are making more holes
And once again
We are doing this so that you don't have to break your brand-new Pongfinity balls
When you get them from our store
Before and after!
Let's try it!
It's...
I don't know what's wrong with it
Okay this is well over 50 holes
It's like there's something wierd about it
It doesn't grip
Like it... drops down
The sound is so wierd
Can you hear the sound?
Less spin, less speed and a wierd sound
That was good
Thanks!
To the next challenge!
Okay next let's try to do some net serves
One
Two
Three
Four
Five
Six
Seven
Eight
Nine
Nice!
The one who drops out last wins!
Ready, set, go!
Nice rhytm
This is intense
Ok so the idea is to get one bounce
Pass it over
Two bounces
Until you miss!
Ooh, it's still in!
But that was four, no!
I miscounted!
Nice!
Yes!
No!
This is really fun to play actually!
This is so addicting!
We just wanna beat the record!
Good save!
Okay Emil, five!
Oh sorry!
That was a really good save to get the fifth
On table still
Definitely not an easy challenge!
You have to try this out!
See how many you can get
And remember to check out our very own Pongfinity balls
They are professional level table tennis balls
And we use them in all of our filming sessions
You can get them from www.pongfinity.store
Until next time!
Seven
Eight
Nooo!!
It goes hard, if you hit it hard